كان في نقطه مهمه دائما ما يتم تردادها
بشان الوضع العام في ليبيا وهي مساله
التفلت السلاح يعني وجود السلاح ليس في يد
الدوله حسره همم هذا الامر برايك انه
المجتمع الدولي لازم يحله ولا في اتفاق
لبداخلي يجب ان ينهي هذه المساله في لبنان
مثلا لم تستطع الدوله حصر السلاح في يد
الدوله في العراق حتى بعد انتخابات
وحكومات لم تستطع الدوله حصر السلاح في يد
الدوله ما الذي يعني اذا لم ياتي الامر من
الداخل الليبي لن يكون هناك قدره على على
ان يؤمر الشارع الليبي فيطاع بانه يجب ان
يكون السلاح بيد الدوله ما رايك
صدقت هذا عمليه مشتركه يعني زي ما قلت لك
للفصل السابع والاقرارات مجلس الامن واللي
وضعت ليبيا تحت رعايه تامه من قبل
مجلس الامن انه هو ينظم تنظيم السلاح
ويكون هذا السلاح تحت المؤسسات الرسميه هو
الجيش الوطني والامن الوطني وفي نفس الوقت
هناك مسؤوليه على الاداره المحليه يعني هي
تبدا في هذا الامر الدير اعلانات تشجع
الناس تبدا في جمع السلاح ما ما عاش تسمح
باي سيدي خارج السلطه بس احنا امبارح في
سبها في المعارك قبل من اسبوعين ثلاثه في
طرابلس في همم في معارك ليش لان السلاح
مشكله خطيره جدا السلاح يحتاج ان يكون عند
ناس يعني يحترم القانون عند مؤسسه تحترم
القانون ولا كان هذا يهدد السلم الاجتماعي
في البلد الخوف انه ما يضل مساله بهذا
السياق لانه سمعنا تصريحات من خليفه حفتر
تحذر صراحه من حرب جديده برايك ما الذي
دفعوا لمثل هذه المواقف الى اي حد تبدو
معقوله انه تتصاعد الامور في الشارع
الليبي لنصل الى حرب اهليه
المشاكل بتاعها الناس اللي تصرخ في الشارع
المواطن يصرف في الشارع ما فيش حد يكتب في
المواطن يعمل روحي بالبلدي اعمل اجتماع
عدلي المنطقه هذه اعمل اجتماع لا والله ما
اتفقناش لا الناس ما تتفقش والمراه
والمشايخ اللي تراكم الساده وما فيش حلول
الان اصعب شيء عن المواطن الليبي هو
الحصول على قوه
الجانب الصحي سيء جدا اه مرض السرطان في
ليبي رحمه الله
تعالى موجودين في كل الانحاء الدول اللي
حولنا
ان الدوله مش قادره تغطي نفقات ثم تغطي
احتياجاتهم الاساسيه
ان شاء الله الاطفال اللي عندنا فيه مشكله
يعني احنا وصلنا لمرحله سيئه جدا هذا
الوضع ربما يدفع بعض الناس
تحدثت عليه حضرتك
هذا الامر احنا معاه لازم نفكر في الحل
السلمي لان احنا جربنا المعارك يا استاذ
منتهى هذه فيها خساره لاولادنا ولى
ثرواتنا
ويخلق انتقام لان اي شخص بينتقل الى رحمه
الله وصرته واهلا يعني بينتقموا بيفكروا
بطريقه اخرى سيئه وبينظروا المجتمع نظره
سوداويه احنا نبن حلو المشكله سلميه
والدين بالعقل بصناديق الانتخابات
بالمشاركه الجماعيه بمشاركه المجتمعيه